what am I gonna do for two weeks without
you I'm hitting the road I can't wait to
see you I miss you
[Music]
cook I drove it and I drove all the way
across the country just because she
wanted to be on a stupid singing
competition I never trusted her honey
too much eyeliner means she's hiding
something obviously I am single and then
broke and I'm back home living with my
mom Oh Oh all should play here okay
thank you so much for coming out now I
know how Beyonce feels Beyonce still
lives with her mom right you know I
actually saw you perform the other night
I'm Elise
Bex and you fool me twice and fold down
okay why would you ever in a million
years be here well hello they're not our
people
that's um coolants what poor girl's life
are you ruining now you thought you had
it figured
you know that she's the wife of my good
friend right to the sunny you said two
months ago you were left for Lucy and
now who's gonna be next month
then we all just wanna go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sweetie
[Music]
Oh
you